make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and
once again we're discussing the most
powerful characters in comics in our
beyond omega-level series and today
we're gonna be taking a look at a
character who's not only one of the most
powerful characters but also one of the
strangest in ego the Living Planet now
if you've watched guardians of the
galaxy volume 2 which I'm assuming
almost all of you have you're somewhat
familiar with this character and I say
somewhat because the version of the
character that's portrayed by Kurt
Russell is vastly different than the
comic book character he was based on so
the comic book version of ego was
created by Stan Lee and Jack Kirby and
first appeared in Thor number 132 in
1966 now in telling the story behind the
creation of ego Jack Kirby who at the
time was really interested in the
universe as a concept said he wanted to
do a different spin on the classic
science fiction trope of a living planet
by creating a planet that was relatable
and explaining to readers why it was
alive and so he envisioned a virus that
was totally isolated for millions of
years
and began to evolve to the point that
when it was reached by humans it would
have developed sentient thought and
would think of itself to be far superior
to humans hence the name ego now yo
along with Galactus in the creek was one
of the earliest characters introduced as
part of Marvel's cosmic mythos and so
looking at his first appearance the
description of ego that we get pretty
much matches Kirby's inspiration what we
end up seeing is Thor aiding a race of
galactic colonizers known as the Rogell
ian's who had been repeatedly attacked
by ego now Thor goes with the ridge
elion to the center of the black galaxy
which is described as existing not
within the physical universe but in a
fluid bio verse and at the center of the
black galaxy lies ego and right away
ego puts a demonstration of what he is
capable of after declaring that his
powers are endless he changes his
surface to include a face that he can
converse with Thor and then Terra forms
himself to reassemble Asgard knowing
that Thor will find those surroundings
more familiar now in doing this he
demonstrates the ability to manipulate
matter on a molecular level ego is also
able to create a humanoid life-form
based on Thor's molecular structure out
of egos own antibodies and states that
his plan is to create billions of them
to aid him in his newfound quest to
conquer the universe however by the end
of his first encounter with Thor he's
defeated and those never to leave his
blot galaxy or try to conquer the cosmos
again but of course that doesn't last
because nothing ever does in comic books
and so for decades we didn't really know
much about egos origins but all that
changed in 2010 during the astonishing
Thor miniseries by Rob rody once
revealed that ego was actually created
by the cosmic entity known as the
stranger who's basically a universal
scientist now in order to create a
living planet the stranger needed
materials belonging to the collector and
in exchange for allowing him to use
those materials the stranger agreed to
create a second living planet for the
collector to keep in his museum now the
stranger agreed and created both ego who
would live his life with autonomy and
alter ego who would be kept in isolation
within a pocket universe in the
collectors museum now the stranger also
reveals that when he created ego he gave
him his own personality and force of
will hence why he decided to name him
ego furthermore after the stranger
informs ego of the existence of his twin
he imbues him with the ability to travel
through hyperspace thereby increasing
his power level even further but even
with that new information
EKOS full origin had not been revealed
and we learned even more about him
during a Ewing's recent Ultimates to run
and so what we learned here is that The
Strangers experiment had created ego and
alter ego had actually used two planets
that orbited the same star and that on
one of those planets village' scientists
named a gross now when the stranger
caused the Sun to explode all the
inhabitants of egress his planet
including himself died and his
consciousness became the consciousness
of ego and this is all revealed during a
conversation with Galactus who at this
point is not the devourer of worlds but
a life bringer and so with egos origins
sounds familiar
it's probably because it's similar to
Galactus as origin who was formerly the
scientist known as Galan now the two of
them even find a form of kinship over
their similarity and Galactus eventually
gives ego a physical body transforming
him into a new version of himself known
as ego pran and so now that we finally
got an egos origin explained we can
finally move on to what his powers are
kind of a fun fact though there was one
point in Marvel Comics when Galactus
ended up strapping a rocket to the
ascend of ego and sent him flying
through the universe it was hilarious
and so having said that I've already has
discussed a few of egos powers and
telling his origin story for instance we
discussed his ability to manipulate
matter and also tear form his own
surface into whatever manner he chooses
he can also create whatever weather he
desires creates shields to protect
himself from damage and reach out into
space with large tentacles capable of
destroying spacecraft that vent
too close to him and not really a power
but more of an aspect of his physiology
ego can absorb beings and digest them
but we also discussed that he can create
a seemingly unlimited number of humanoid
antibodies that defend ego from any
intruders much like the antibodies that
we have in our blood streams to protect
us from viruses ego is also able to
control these antibodies telepathically
and he's able to possess immense psionic
powers egos telepathic powers are also
so potent that he was able to read
Thanos his mind and attempt to drive him
insane by mentally recreating every
being that Thanos had ever killed no ego
is also able to channel his psionic
ability to energy blasts that are
capable of destroying not only starships
but entire planets
when egos energy reserves are drained
he's able to replenish them by siphoning
energy from other living things planets
or stars he's also able to manipulate
his own atmosphere including his
gravitational pull and so he's able to
command one of the fundamental forces of
nature as well as his magnetic and
radiation fields and so the potential is
definitely there for ego to destroy
multiple planets if he chose to which
means that we can safely categorize ego
as beyond omega-level in fact ego would
probably have killed his brother alter
ego had Thor not intervened but his
attack before that point had greatly
reduced the size of alter ego to the
point that alter ego was reduced from a
planet to a moon and began orbiting ego
Galactus had even tried on more than one
occasion to devour ego and satiate his
hunger and had been unsuccessful each
time and so that suggested there's not a
hugely significant power difference
between the two just to give you an
example of how powerful ego is so yeah
ego the Living Planet it ought to be
pretty fun to look at one of the weirder
aspects of the Marvel landscape and kind
of give you guys an idea of how powerful
he is but let me know what you guys
think do you guys enjoy it do you guys
think it was fun do you guys think ego
sucks if you are new here to come and
explain make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the rob4 if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all
later
peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]